[Music]
guys there are a few things in league of
legends that get your blood flowing like
a good solo kill whether it's one player
stepping up in a crazy teamfight to
dumpster everybody or it's a true 1v1
solo kills our league of legends
mechanics checkers who is this guy
now add in a crazy crowd and some high
stakes and well some of these plays can
be career-defining oh yeah and I'm
supposed to tell you to listen to the
podcast versions of our don't Abney and
story of videos and you probably should
because I'm in a lot of them anyways
this week on top 10 we're looking at the
top 10 solo kills in League of Legends
history let's get things started with
the 2015 midseason Invitational that saw
febiven become a demon slayer matched up
against sk telecom t1 in the semi-finals
the young european mid laner didn't even
flinch when he came face to face with
the unkillable demon king himself so the
visits into the jungle not as fruitful
that there's the Jeff Barr coming in and
will it be enough
[Applause]
then the best part is debbye then didn't
stop there
down again against an aggressive pick
making team faker eats two shuriken
'he's the knock-up is interrupted as
better than materializes ignite
[Applause]
to the game
[Applause]
even though SKT went on to win the game
FEHB events heroic out plays definitely
left Baker's ego just a little bruised
before they were team aids captain parks
were rival mid laners and in Game two of
his EU LCS debut it looked like a young
caps would be solo killed byes future
teammate but thanks to a clutch flash
caps managed to turn the play around
living up to his baby faker nicknamed
being annoying and caps didn't get to
push out number eight on our list sees a
1v1 between the next generation of
Korean mid laners Jovi and you kow were
trading blows during the lck 2018 summer
split finals looking for any edge they
could get and in Game two you Cal found
that edge in the form of a perfectly
placed stun the turned into this
beautiful solo kill knowing where Zoe
would return to you Cal landed a nasty
stun onto cho v which he punished with
some top-notch mechanics in a well-timed
cleanse next up is this unforgettable
mid lane duel from the 2016 World
Championship quarterfinals one kill
behind crowns Cassiopeia cloud nines mid
laner Jensen looked to even up the score
line with a solo kill thick ambition was
gonna get there in time meteos just the
edge
[Applause]
even though crown tried to fight back
with his petrifying gaze Jensen proved
that staying calm cool and collected in
the face of danger
always pays off guys grab your time
machine because this next play harkens
all the way back to the 2014 na LCS
summer split in a time when full ap solo
Lane Gragas was still a thing LM Q's top
laner Ackerman taught CLG Seraph that
you should never mess with a big boy
especially when he's holding a cake
[Applause]
oh the dominoes falling marking the
halfway point in our list is this
classic Baker play from the NLB 2014
summer finals
just because 2014 was a down year for
SKT doesn't mean that Baker still wasn't
doing what he does best
[Music]
unfortunately for najin black sword mid
laner Kuro he would feel the unkillable
demon King's wrath it was any other mid
laner curl would probably have found
that solo kill but the man made a grave
mistake in trying to fight faker in his
prime at number 4 we have this plate
courtesy of the LPL's top lane god the
shine coming off his 2018 World
Championship win the shy return to the
LPL with the swagger of a champion
something that the three ganking members
of Team W II would learn the hard way
sigh oh my goodness the shy going right
back yesterday walks up the a they carry
magic it's gonna get nothing ground with
them I can't believe the shy right now
not only does the shy buy time for
rookie to arrive but the 2018 world
champion also found two solo kills of
his own right now next up on our list is
this bill key play from a top lane
legend of course we're talking about
smeb who had a top lane duel interrupted
by a gank attempt that didn't go the way
afreeca so coming in right here spent
just playing around that video wave gets
on top of Pixar using that speed that he
gets try and get that Dominion work
Wayne's gonna finish him off Lyra just
sticks around inside the parallel
convergence map gets the shield falls
off though before you do any damage and
then he's just trying to play around the
outside of the wave against comes back
in with the next phase dive then gets
that Smackdown he'll you had to have
known that this legendary play from the
2014 World Championship would make its
way near the top of our list minding his
own business
fanatics expec a and his jungle farming
interrupted when da day that came out of
nowhere to try to kill him but the
generals plan fell apart in an instant
the fights def just finishes Trinity
force got it going down but is it going
to be enough Sunday
using his death mark to avoid some of
the damage from talons ultimate expect a
burst da de down with a single rotation
of his abilities plus a clutch ignite
fnatic may not have ended up winning the
game but that didn't stop their Spanish
mid laner from adding yet another
incredible highlight to his collection I
think you can already guess what's
number one on this list it's none other
than fakers legendary Zed 1 B 1 versus
Ryu at the 2013 lck champions summer
finals and despite being over 6 years
old now this outplay remains a timeless
from the complex movements made between
faker and Ryu to its dazzling conclusion
and iconic caster call this solo kill
encapsulate everything great about
competitive League of Legends
although Ryu might not agree well guys
that is the end of the video and if
you've stuck around till this point I'm
going to imagine you're already
subscribe to the channel you already
like the video and you're already gonna
comment so instead of telling you to do
all that stuff I'm gonna ask you to tell
me who would solo kill in the 1v1
between the score eSports hosts come on
you know it's me I'm getting the Penta
let's go guys there are a few things in
League of Legends that'll get your blood
going like a good solo kill oh yeah and
I was supposed to tell you - what
[Music]
I'm I'm crazy but I'm not that crazy
[Music]